get ready to ring in the new year with
Pro Hamas agitators the anti-israel crew
is getting a practice run on what they
hope to do this New Year's Eve dozens of
them getting arrested for blocking
roadways outside major travel hubs
including New York City's JFK Airport
they also made life pretty miserable for
travelers at LAX the blockades forcing
some flyers to burst through the signs
on foot to bypass jammed roadway
unfortunately we might see this type of
nonsense as we count down to 2024
protesters are expected to Target the
Times Square ball drop but mayor Adams
promises that the NYPD will be on top of
things there's always a serious concern
around safety in New Year's Eve because
there's a large number of people
everyone you know look for uh events
like this if they want to do bad things
and the police department is on top of
it yeah we'll see um look there's a lot
of uh very uh serious and dark stuff to
get to but big picture Kennedy um is
this working are they winning over are
they winning any friends by doing this
no I went and bought a star of David
necklace after seeing yet another Pro
Palestine protest I mean they're they're
calling for genocide and they smell
they're not changing anyone's mind I got
caught up in one of these dingbat
protests in uh Columbus Circle and you
know the mall there they had shut the
mall down I'm like I just trying to go
to Lululemon and get my daughter a pair
of leggings Before Christmas can you a
hats please just move out of the way
because all you're doing is making the
case for the other side and all people
have to do is a little bit of research
to see that they intellectually
undermine themselves every time they
show up and scream into bullhorns and
you know what it is protest tourism
these are people who have been bored fat
and unemployed since 2020 a George Floyd
protest and they're just looking for
something to do yep so maybe they're
actually helping but you know I have to
say it's all of it is appalling but I
have to say that watching people jump
out of their cabs at LAX to run I mean
Jimmy the wor a cab driver's worst
nightmare oh well what's going on right
now oh yeah especially because again
it's not people that are legitimately
invested in the cause if there was like
a true educated passion yes how these
guys think Gaza Strip is a gentleman's
club they have no idea they're like
should I bring singles to the protest
we're going Gaza Strip This sounds great
but back to Kennedy's point of how they
are insufferable people who don't have
the skill of persuasion okay no one no
one is sitting in that cab at LAX going
oh my gosh they made me miss my flight
they destroyed my honeymoon I'm going to
adapt their political views I think
these are the people I need to be with
and that's the problem as for Time
Square I'm not going there okay as a
Jets fan I've been watching the ball
drop all year good night everybody there
it is there it is uh you know Katie um
obviously uh you know when you have
these unbelievable stories where they're
like Christmas carolers are getting like
crashed with uh people saying things
like uh Long Live inata and Christmas is
canceled it start you start to wonder if
maybe there might not be like a distinct
religious element inata is a call for
murder a call for genocide uh these
people are not interested in Persuasion
what we're seeing is a an effort to
intimidate and to use terrorist tactics
to shut down freeways and to harass
people and to scare children with their
families going to a Christmas tree or
trying to get on a flight maybe for a
family emergency they're interested in
control they're not interested in having
a a debate about this topic it's Occupy
Wall Street antifa the 2020 riers
repackaged into this for the most part
but historically when it comes to the
airports in the 60s and 70s there were
about a dozen hijacked planes by
Palestinian terrorists so this is
actually a real problem and a threat
that we've seen throughout the course of
modern history and law enforcement
should treat it as such before things
get much worse these are not people who
are interested in democracy or having a
discussion about human rights they're
interested in murdering people and
making sure that you know if you cross
them that you'll be on the the list next
and as you point out they're not going
to leave anybody behind they start with
the Jewish delies and the the hummus
place down the street and then they go
to the Christmas trees they want you to
take their side or else okay so a new
level of dark uh in all of this for me
was this whole idea of uh this group
wanting to hold a protest outside the DC
uh Holocaust Museum inside inside inside
the DC Holocaust Museum I mean this is
nuts it's beyond nuts um it's one of the
more uneducated movements I think that
we've ever witnessed before total lack
of respect for Humanity for history for
the national Consciousness like read the
room people people are upset about this
on both sides of it but anyone who's
being thoughtful about it knows that the
Holocaust Museum here and in Israel
Hallowed Ground it's sacred your life
will be changed if you spend five
minutes in either of those museums it's
appalling um what they are doing is also
alienated alienating Israelis who are
some of the most supportive people of
the Palestinian cause Gallup just
recorded the highest level of support of
I'm kind of inverted against a two-state
solution I think I did that inverted but
they used to be a lot more supportive of
it and now they're saying you know what
this is who you are this is how you're
treating us
and it is
harrowing and I would still recommend it
there is a New York Times investigation
piece that came out today called screams
without words how Hamas weaponized
sexual violence on October 7th you
should go and look at it this is just a
little excerpt of it says the first
victim said she saw a young woman with
copper colored hair blood running down
her back pants pushed down to her knees
one man pulled her by the hair and made
her bend over another penetrated her and
every time she flinched he plunged a
knife into her back that is all that
this is about it is not about free
Palestine the time for free Palestine is
when all of these hostages have been
returned we found out another American
hostage was dead today her husband was
also been
murdered just hold hold it for a second
and wait until your people are returned
you'll be you'll get a more amenable
conversation out of it as well but when
people are sitting there being
bludgeoned and raped and killed by the
day no one wants to see this and they're
making a mockery of themselves they're
making a mockery of the situ this dire
situation in the Middle East and you're
emboldening BB Netanyahu yeah I think no
civilized person wants to see this uh
but you but you have to kind of wonder
about some of these people who look at
this on October 7th and then come out on
the side of the terrorists yeah you kind
of right scratch your head and think
maybe some people do want to see yeah
how are you the president of Harvard
right exactly hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox newss
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else